con las que trabajó en el pasado,
las personas con las que uno fue a la escuela,
estas personas nos recuerdan como éramos
antes de la pausa en la carrera.
Y es así incluso si la propia autoestima ha disminuido con el tiempo,
como nos sucede a muchos
cuanto más alejados estamos de nuestras identidades profesionales.
Así, por ejemplo, uno puede verse
como alguien así.
Esta soy yo, loca tras un día de conducir en mi camioneta.
O aquí estoy en la cocina.
Pero esas personas del pasado,
no saben nada de esto.
Solo recuerdan cómo fuimos
y da mucha confianza entrar nuevamente en contacto con estas personas
y escuchar su entusiasmo sobre nuestro interés por regresar al trabajo.
Hay algo más que recuerdo nítidamente de mi propia pausa en la carrera.
Y es que me costaba mantenerme al tanto de las noticias del negocio.
Tengo formación en finanzas,
y me costaba mantenerme al tanto
al llegar a casa y tener que cuidar a mis cuatro hijos.
Por eso temía ir a una entrevista y empezar a hablar
de una empresa que ya no existía.
Tuve que suscribirme al Wall Street Journal
y leer portada tras portada durante seis meses
hasta que sentí que de nuevo tenía una idea de lo que pasaba en los negocios.
Creo que los relanzadores son una joya del mundo laboral,
y les diré por qué.
Piensen en nuestra etapa en la vida:
quienes hicimos una pausa para cuidar a los niños,
tenemos pocas o ninguna baja por maternidad.
Ya la tuvimos.
Tenemos menos reubicaciones conyugales relativas al trabajo.
Estamos en una etapa más estable de la vida.
Tenemos mucha experiencia laboral.
Tenemos una perspectiva más madura.
Intentamos no estar a merced de un empleador.
Además, tenemos energía y entusiasmo por regresar al trabajo,
precisamente porque estuvimos alejados durante un tiempo.
Por otro lado, hablo con los empleadores,
y tienen dos pegas
a la hora de contratar relanzadores.
La primera es que los empleadores temen que los relanzadores
estén obsoletos en tecnología.
Pero, puedo decirles,
habiendo estado obsoleta en tecnología en cierto momento,
que es una condición temporal.
Había hecho análisis financiero hace tanto que usaba Lotus 1-2-3.
No sé si alguien puede incluso recordar algo de aquello,
pero tuve que reaprender a hacerlo en Excel.
En realidad no fue tan difícil. Muchos de los comandos son iguales.
Para mí PowerPoint fue un reto mucho mayor,
pero ahora lo uso todo el tiempo.
Le digo a los relanzadores que los empleadores esperan
que ya vengan con el conocimiento laboral del software básico de gestión.
Y que si no están al corriente,
es su responsabilidad estarlo.
Y lo hacen.
El otro aspecto que preocupa a los empleadores sobre los relanzadores
es que los relanzadores no sepan qué quieren hacer.
Les digo a los relanzadores que tienen que esforzarse mucho
por averiguar si sus habilidades e intereses han cambiado
o no han cambiado
durante la pausa en la carrera.
No es tarea del empleador averiguarlo.
Es responsabilidad del relanzador demostrarle al empleador
dónde puede aportar más valor.
Allá por 2010 empecé a notar algo.
Había estado siguiendo programas de reinserción laboral desde 2008,
y en 2010 empecé a escuchar
el término oportunidades laborales con pagas de corto plazo,
llámese periodo de prácticas o no,
una experiencia similar a la pasantía,
como forma de reinserción laboral.
Vi que Goldman Sachs y Sara Lee
empezaron con programas de pasantías de reinserción corporativa.
Vi regresar a una ingeniera, un reingreso atípico,
solicitar el ingreso al programa de pasantías en el servicio militar,
y luego conseguir un empleo permanente.
Vi que dos universidades integraron becarios
en programas ejecutivos de educación de mitad de carrera.
Así que escribí un informe de lo que estaba viendo,
y dio lugar a este artículo de Harvard Business Review
titulado "El becario de 40 años".
Debo agradecer a los editores por ese título,
y también por esta obra de arte
donde se ve un pasante de 40 años en medio de pasantes universitarios.
Y luego, por cortesía de Fox Business News,
llamaron al concepto "El becario de 50 años".
(Risas)
Cinco de las empresas más grandes de servicios financieros
tienen programas de reinserción por pasantías de profesionales de finanzas.
Hasta el momento, han participado cientos de personas.
Estos becarios reciben una paga,
y las personas que pasan a empleos permanentes
reciben salarios competitivos.
Ahora, siete de las empresas más grandes de ingeniería
están probando programas de reinserción por pasantías con ingenieras
como parte de una iniciativa con la Sociedad de Ingenieras.
¿Por qué adoptan las empresas las pasantías de reinserción?
Porque la pasantía le permite al empleador
basar la decisión de la contratación en una muestra real del trabajo
en vez de a partir de entrevistas,
y el empleador no tiene que tomar esa decisión de contratación
hasta que expire el período de pasantía.
Este período de prueba elimina el riesgo percibido
que algunos gerentes asocian a contratar relanzadores,
y están atrayendo excelentes candidatos
que terminan en grandes contratos.
Piensen en lo lejos que hemos llegado.
Antes, a la mayoría de los empleadores no le interesaba
entrar en contacto con relanzadores.
Pero ahora, no solo se desarrollan programas
específicamente para relanzadores,
sino que no se puede participar en estos programas
a menos que uno tenga una laguna en el CV.
Esta es la prueba del cambio real,
del verdadero cambio institucional,
porque si podemos resolver este problema para los relanzadores,
podemos resolverlo también para otras situaciones de transición.
De hecho, un empleador me dijo
que su programa de reinserción laboral de veteranos
se basa en su programa de reinserción por pasantías.
Y podría existir un programa de pasantía para jubilados.
Distinto grupo, mismo concepto.
Ahora les contaré qué pasa con Tracy Shapiro.
Recuerdan que ella tuvo que contarle a todos
sobre su interés por volver al trabajo.
Bueno, una conversación clave con otro padre en su comunidad
dio lugar a una oferta para Tracy,
era un trabajo de contabilidad en un departamento de finanzas.
Pero era un empleo temporal.
La empresa le dijo que existía una posibilidad
de convertirse en algo más, pero no había garantías.
Esto fue en el otoño de 2011.
Tracy amaba a esta empresa, y a las personas,
y la oficina quedaba a menos de 10 minutos de su casa.
Por eso, aunque tenía otra oferta
en otra empresa, y era un puesto a tiempo completo,
decidió arriesgarse con esta pasantía
y esperar lo mejor.
Bueno, terminó excediendo con creces todas sus expectativas,
y la empresa no solo le hizo una oferta permanente
a principios de 2012,
sino que se puso más interesante y fue un desafío mayor,
porque sabían de lo que Tracy era capaz.
Pasamos rápidamente a 2015:
Tracy recibió una promoción.
Le pagaron un MBA para que lo haga por las noches.
Ella incluso contrató a otro relanzador que trabaja para ella.
El empleo temporal de Tracy fue una prueba,
como una pasantía,
y terminó siendo una ganancia tanto para Tracy como para su empleador.
Mi objetivo es llevar la idea de la reinserción por pasantía
a cada vez más empleadores.
Pero, mientras tanto,
si Uds. regresan al trabajo tras una pausa en su carrera,
no duden en sugerir un acuerdo de pasantía o similar
a un empleador que no tiene un programa formal de reinserción.
Sean su primer caso de éxito,
Uds. pueden ser el ejemplo para muchos futuros relanzadores.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)